a man hunted by a shadowy enclave of men
in a male ruled dystopia let's mix it up
from ice cold classics to waterlogged
flops we're playing what if on some
iconic sci-fi and fantasy roles
john carpenter's the thing was a flop at
the box office but it became a cult
classic and is now regarded as a sci-fi
horror masterpiece it is also a film
that has zero female characters in fact
the only female voice in the film is a
computer playing chess against mccready
in the opening scene and that gets
killed off pretty early check me
check me
[Music]
kurt russell is certainly legendary in
the lead role and the film is all but
perfect but it's fun to ask what if so
imagine if mcgreedy was played by a
woman instead it could have actually
been great the thing with its original
cast was excellent but throwing a woman
into the mix especially as mccready
could have given the film more complex
interpersonal dynamics to explore max
paranoia would have been multiplied by
being the only woman in the wilderness
with a group of men breaking under
pressure a female mag could have tackled
incorrect perceived notions that women
are the overly emotional ones flipping
that notion on its head by being the
only one to maintain a cool head in a
crisis alien did it and the thing could
have easily gone in that fascinating
direction the 2011 prequel of the thing
did feature a female in the lead role
however as mary elizabeth winstead
portrayed kate lloyd
that's swedish
kevin reynolds water world was a misfire
of epic proportions the kind that spent
the next several years as a hollywood
punchline could it have been salvaged by
a female playing a mutated loner with
gills though one of the film's many
shortcomings was an awkward quasi-love
story between kevin costner's mariner
and helen which simply didn't work so
set aside and start anew either making
it a same-sex romance or re-casting the
hell and role with the male and perhaps
that chemistry could work it certainly
couldn't be much worse seeing two women
work together to get a child to the
safety of dry land may have been a more
interesting and emotionally resonant
film waterworld could have been a film
about a reluctant heroine with the
courage to trust and help others despite
fears of judgment rather than an aloof
story about an embittered loner
i better not screw up my short game
city barely earned back its production
budget despite getting praise from
critics and being one of only a handful
of films that was so beloved by roger
ebert that he recorded an audio
commentary for every scene of the film
but could it have done better at the box
office with a leading lady in the rufus
sewell role considering that the
strangers are all men it would have been
interesting to have sewell's murdock
played by someone of a different gender
the film's theme suggests we as humans
have more power in our lives than we
might think having a woman possess the
ability to alter her environment and to
manifest the world she wants to live in
would have been a powerful and
surprising message for a sci-fi film at
the time science fiction is a genre that
can give a voice to traditionally
marginalized groups by casting a male
lead dark city missed an opportunity to
embrace a subversive rebellious power of
science fiction and this story so it
seems you've discovered your unpleasant
nature
when carnaval premiered it seemed
destined for greatness winning five
emmys receiving positive reviews and
developing a solid fanbase sadly the
series lost its audience after season
one concluded limping through the next
season before being cancelled but if
they'd cast ben hawkins as a woman
instead of nick stahl this fascinating
and influential series might have been
even more interesting with the female
hawkins the show wouldn't just have a
battle brewing between good and evil as
the awesome introduction of the series
sets up it could have explored the
patriarchy pitted against the matriarchy
carnival could have had plot lines based
around christianity and the church of
men stamping out pagan nature religions
and the divine feminine having hawkin's
opponent in this conflict represented by
brother justin crowe already set up this
dynamic with the suggestion that
female-led entertainment is no longer a
financial risk this supernatural period
drama could be begging for a female-led
reboot
[Music]